tel aviv israels metropole am mittelmeer
sie strotzt vor lebensfreude und trotz
der realität
denn nirgendwo sonst lässt sich der
nahost konflikt wohl besser verdrängen
als hier
in tel aviv findest du einfach alles und
das liebe ich unser motto ist leben und
leben lassen
[Musik]
vom rothschild boulevard bis ins
arabische jaffa die tel aviver machen
das beste aus jeder situation und
kreieren ihre eigene welt wir geben hier
ein gutes beispiel ab dass koexistenz
funktioniert die begriffe araber oder
jude versuchen wir nicht zu benutzen
nur eins können tel aviv seinen
bewohnern nie eine atempause
[Musik]
vor seinem schlag fürchtet sich immer
noch jeder gegner
amnon ist im 73 jahre alt bekannt als am
die kanone er ist der ungekrönte könig
von tel aviv und matt also strand ennest
ist der heimliche nationalsport folly
frei magath bringt den menschen hier
freude und das brauchen sie es entspannt
uns alle hier mit all diesen
schwierigkeiten in israel but caused tut
einfach gut
strand sonne und matt wenn es in tel
aviv mal wieder stressig und hektisch
wird und im radio wieder mal von der
steigenden terrorgefahr die rede ist
flüchten sich amon und seine freunde
hier her
die ganze woche ist hier immer hart dann
kommt das wochenende man will dass alles
abschütteln den ball so hart wie möglich
schlagen das ist die therapie den
therapie termin versäumen würden sie nie
zumal amon ihn zusätzlich mit kuchen
versucht ein liebgewonnenes ritual
[Musik]
auch der gang auf den karmel markt im
stadtzentrum ist für viele eine kleine
flucht und ein dankbares ritual bei dem
man sich für einen moment verlieren und
den verlockungen hingeben kann selbst
kennen und yael zwei gefragte köchin
können dieser kleinen kostprobe nicht
widerstehen
[Musik]
frische peter mit salat und sesam soße
mehr ist es nicht
[Musik]
doch selbst die einfachsten gerichte
schmecken so gut dass israelisches essen
mittlerweile ein exportschlager weltweit
ist
wir sind einfach gute köche in israel
wir lieben es gut zu essen und wir
israelis sind aus aller welt in dieses
land gekommen und jede mitgebrachte
spezialität wird von uns genutzt sie mit
etwas anderem zu kombinieren so dass
etwas tolles neues entsteht natürlich
frisch wir haben hier auch einfach super
zutaten und wir haben einen guten
geschmack ich will damit nicht sagen
dass ihr uns nicht ab
kerrin und yael kochen nicht nur
zusammen sie sind auch ein paar in tel
aviv ist man stolz auf die eigene
toleranz
egal ob homo oder hetero tel aviv lebt
jeden und ist damit die einzige stadt im
nahen osten schon in jerusalem sehe das
ganz anders aus auch religion spielt
hier nicht so eine große rolle
und so bleiben diese hasen auf dem markt
stehen und die herren im roten mantel
finden auch keinen liebhaber
denn für teure import schokolade
produziert für christliche feiertage
haben die tel aviver bei aller toleranz
nichts übrig kevin und yael haben alles
gefunden was sie für ihr menü brauchen
eigentlich wollten die beiden ein
eigenes restaurant aufmachen aber in tel
aviv ist einfach alles zu teuer
mieten pacht personal doch jedem problem
jeder note begegnung die tel aviver mit
kreativität kennt ja als idee
kommerziell kochen und auf der privaten
terrasse servieren
und damit haben sie hier einen trend
gesetzt
profiköche laden zu sich nach hause ein
alle sind lokale gerichte und wir
bereiten alles bei uns zu und das kann
man schmecken gebucht und bezahlt haben
die gäste im voraus über eine
internetseite
das konzept kommt an kein platz bleibt
frei
die experimente jenseits der klischees
und vor allem lieben wir na sagen wir
die zwischenmenschliche interaktion so
sind wir hier in tel aviv
du gehst einfach in die wohnung von
jemand anderem und hast keine hemmungen
alles zu genießen dich ein bisschen zu
betrinken und party zu machen
das geht nur hier
ihre träume einfach der situation
anpassen darin sind die tel aviver
meister
[Applaus]
auch am 9
der matt kurt könig lebt seinen traum
und öffnet stets sein haus für fremde
menschen
es sieht dem stadtteil magix hätte amnon
hat es in ein privates museum verwandelt
besucher erwünscht eintritt frei
[Musik]
eigentlich ist das hier kein museum
sondern ein palast ich bin der könig und
lebe in meinem palast dass so viele
tausend menschen mich besuchen tut mir
gut
für seine besucher liegt am neuen gerne
deutsche schlager auf amnon versteht
zwar kein deutsch aber er mag den klang
fast so sehr wie das klack klack des
smart cottbus und dann erzählt er aus
vergangenen tagen als der staat und er
noch ganz jung waren und die straßen von
tel aviv so sandig wie heute nur der
strand von anderen zeiten und der
entstehung tel avivs erzählen auch diese
gebäude im bauhausstil tel aviv ist die
bauhaus metropole
nirgendwo sonst auf der welt rein sich
mehr kubistische wohn würfel mit wunsch
schwingenden balkonen aneinander
manche machen dem namen weiße stadt wie
tel avivs bauhaus viertel mit rund 4.000
gebäuden genannt wird alle ehre
andere warten noch auf ihre sanierung
und damit auch auf ihn den schwaben
norbert röttgen seit zehn jahren als
selbstständiger restaurator in tel aviv
seine spezialität die richtige mörtel
mischung seine herausforderung die
kulturellen unterschiede check das
nochmal das musst du sehen kapiert
zwei meter ballack ist hebräisch und
heißt chaos und ist eines der
wichtigsten wörter in tel aviv
die stadt ist norbert zweite heimat
geworden dass er mit seiner arbeit zum
erhalt des deutsch jüdischen erbes
beiträgt macht ihn besonders stolz
die jüdischen architekten der weißen
stadt waren fast alle in den 1930 er
jahren aus nazi deutschland geflohen
ihr werk ist heute weltkulturerbe
[Musik]
architektin michael schäfer plant die
sanierung dieses gebäudes und ist froh
norbert an ihrer seite zu haben
man nennt ihn hier herrn kratz putz nein
doktorgrads putzt
er ist wie alle deutschen alles muss
genau sein und perfekt passen es gibt
nur einen weg
sonst sind sie nicht zufrieden und
deshalb engagieren wir ihn auch woran
sich norbert erst gewöhnen musste bei
jeder kern sanierung eines historischen
gebäudes muss ein schutzraum gegen
bomben und raketen eingebaut werden das
ist in israel pflicht
ja das ist gegen bin ich den wunsch
spazieren gegangen und dann habe ich so
was gefühlt das war im zweiten weltkrieg
in deutschland
ich habe es mir glauben wollen dass das
gleiche jetzt ich bin ich bleibe hier
stelle ich mit unserem baum oder aber
ich bin nach hause gelaufen
was soll ich machen er hat das gemacht
was alle tel aviver machen weitermachen
trotz allem auch wenn raketenalarm und
terrorangst immer mitschwingen ihr leben
wollen die tel aviver davon nicht
bestimmen lassen
der arabische stadtteil jaffa
ausgerechnet der ort wo der konflikt am
ehesten spürbar sein müsste gilt als
besonders hip hafen historische altstadt
und flohmarkt sind die attraktionen für
touristen und einheimische
in japan leben muslime christen und
juden zusammen nicht ohne probleme aber
weitgehend konfliktfrei wie das
funktioniert dazu hat hier jeder eine
andere theorie
rami ist orthodoxer jude und gar kein
fan von theorien
er liebt die praxis und sein messer
damit geht er täglich seinen arabischen
kunden an den hals seine frische und
dann wird noch gewachst und geschlemmt
bis kein haar mehr irgendwo ist
rami ist der star unter den klassischen
papieren ruppig aber mit seele und das
kommt an
sami kommt jede woche zu ihm
das hat doch nichts mit jüdisch oder
arabisch zu tun mein herz sagt mir
bayrami bin ich zu hause
[Musik]
rami hat sein handwerk von seinem vater
gelernt und an seine söhne weitergegeben
in stoßzeiten arbeiten sie hier alle
zusammen
für stimmung sorgt neben der musik auch
der neueste klatsch unter einer
bedingung nicht über politik oder
religion reden wir reden nur über
lustigen sachen passwort zu hause was
ist bei der arbeit los oder so politik
ist tabu während rami und seine söhne
noch fleißig an dem harmlosen trend in
jaffa arbeiten beginnt in tel aviv so
langsam das nachtleben die zahllosen
lokale und clubs sind immer voll
feiern bis in die morgenstunden ist
angesagt auch hier jeder nach seinem
geschmack
[Musik]
und so sind auch sie nicht wegzudenken
aus dem tel aviver partyleben orthodoxe
hippies auf mission
ihr motto glaube durch lebensfreude oder
auch feiern bis der messias kommt jeden
donnerstag heißt es keeper auf musik an
und ab geht es mit dem partybus quer
durch die stadt
[Musik]
das einzige was wir wollen ist den
menschen freude bringen sie von ihren
sorgen ablenken oder gar aus der
depression holen
das ist doch eine gute sache selbst wenn
es nur für einen moment anheben und so
ist auch tel aviv
es feiert den moment am liebsten jeden
moment und zwar laut und bunt und
intensiv denn sie wollen hier alle das
beste aus den möglichkeiten machen und
verhalten schon deswegen ihren blick
fest nach vorne gerichtet
[Musik]
[Applaus]